hey everyone welcome to there be
spoilers show I'm the death knight in
this episode we're going to be doing a
big breakdown on all of the latest
Batman news and leaks I'm gonna try and
do a video like this every week just to
keep you up-to-date with the ins and
outs of the movies as there's lots of
leaks every day so I do think the best
way to do it is just do a weekly wrapup
so make sure you subscribe to the
channel to never miss an update
throughout this video we'll be
discussing the Batsuit and Batmobile
details the look of Bruce Wayne and
Gotham the penguin and much much more
there's gonna be heavy spoilers here so
if you don't want anything potentially
ruined about the movie then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of the Batman
okay so first up whilst we haven't seen
the bat suit yet and it is likely that
Warner Brothers have that [ __ ] on
lockdown in the Batcave
there's actually a lot of details that
we know about it now we did get early
descriptions of the suit as being very
similar to the Liebherr maysha one from
graphic novels such as Noelle and Batman
damned this was posted in a tweet by
Variety reporter Chris Tapley who stated
that he'd seen the suit
however he deleted the tweet not long
after but may show did actually post
around the same time what look like
concept of the suit on his Instagram
story but this post too was quickly
taken down so it does look like
something is going on at Warner Brothers
in regards to it
this suit is actually my favorite design
and I know people say that sort of thing
on YouTube all the time but I even got a
tattoo of it a couple of years ago from
a sketch that the artist did and I'm
really excited to see on the big screen
I'm such a bloody spoiler man right I've
been walking around with a crap tattoo
with the leaked Labatt suit on my arm
for years the reason that we haven't
seen it so far is because the production
has now moved to a sound stage and is
shooting these scenes in secure areas so
I doubt you will see any leaked images
similar to the ones that we already have
popping up online when discussing the
suit itself Pattinson said it's been
played in so many different ways the
comics cover so much ground the movies
cover so much ground so I guess it's
kind of what Matt Reeves who is
directing
wants to go for when I was just doing
the screen test and stuff it was pretty
astonishing how different you feel when
you put the Batman costume on you can
have as many ideas as you want and as
soon as you put that costume on it feels
like an entirely different situation
which you could never have predicted so
yeah there is a lot of exciting news
around it finally we did have a reddit
post earlier in the week on DC leaks
that is also since been removed that
said the suit is following a grey and
blue design that feels like a sleeker
version of the Affleck suit the user
posted the following image when saying
what it looks similar to and I really
like the design of it it does line up
with the Bellagio leaks and I definitely
think this will be similar to something
that we get in the final design as for
the Batmobile I actually think we're
gonna be getting full images of this
very very soon UK newspaper The Daily
Record posted an article earlier in the
week saying Glasgow will be transformed
into the Batman's Gotham City and
Scotland's second biggest city will play
a starring role alongside Robert
Pattinson the paper states filming will
start late February which will see parts
of Glasgow made to look like the
fictional home of the Batman and that
filming will give fans the first
opportunity to catch a glimpse of the
new Batmobile the article then went on
to say Glasgow will be turned into
Gotham City and with the city's
architecture it's expected to look great
in the new film it will also be the
first time for DC fans to see the new
Batmobile so there will be lots of them
prepared to stand in the rain hoping
they can spot it anyone who sees the
Batmobile around town will probably look
twice over the years there's been so
many different incarnations of the
Batmobile and it went from looking like
a slick sports car all the way up to
armored tanks that find it easy
bulldozing through cause personally I
believe that this Batmobile will be
toned down slightly and will be more in
line with a sports car than the bat tank
that featured in the Noland films we did
post set leaked images in our last video
that showed Gotham Action News HD vans
and summarized from this that the film
will be set in either the late 90s or
early 2000s this is due to the fact that
HD wasn't invented until around about
that time and that news team's only
really bragged about having it for a
certain amount of years
it was reported by cosmic book news.com
that the Batmobile would be similar and
designed to cause featured around the 90
zero so this once again backs this up
and also adds way to the theory that it
will be a sports car BMWs were very very
popular during that time so who knows we
might even get something similar to a
bond vehicle just make sure it comes in
black it's also likely that Ash Thorpe
is the designer of the vehicle last year
a Twitter user asked if he was working
on the design of it to which you applied
perhaps with a heart Matt Reeves also
posted a picture of Pattinson and
thought follow this up with a smile so
yeah it looks like it will be part of
this in case you don't know Thorpe has
worked on ghost in the shell' Assassin's
Creed the amazing spider-man 2 Ender's
Game Total Recall Person of Interest
Robocop and more you always tends to use
the time setting and movies he works on
two basis designs around so once more I
do think that it would be a more
functional car rather than something
that looks cool now from the information
in the Daily Record article we also now
know what Gotham will look like I've
been to Glasgow several times and in the
winter it has a very atmospheric feel to
it I remember walking through the dim
streets being able to see my own breath
in front of my face and the only light
there being the street lights which
really adds a lot to the location I put
some images on screen now and hopefully
these give you an idea of what the
streets and skyline of the infamous city
could look like I think this is great
and yeah it's an inspired choice to set
it in this city London could have been
an easy go to but it is quite busy and
overrun whereas Glasgow is a bit barren
and quieter so it has this sort of
eeriness to it I know I know I sound
like I'm slugging both the places off
don't dislike this video I'm from
Newcastle it's a it's also a craphole oh
I shouldn't have said that you note down
the dislikes are going to be rolling in
anyway I promise I love them they're
both great and I think the location is
definitely a brilliant choice for the
movie
whoo now before we get into the Bruce
Wayne and Penguin look I just want to
let you know we're giving away a free
copy of dr. sleep to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the leaks in the
comments
below the winners gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of February and the
settle be shipped out from then to ever
gets the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone he takes part okay so we
actually got a potential look at what
Robert Pattinson could look like this
Bruce Wayne earlier this week when the
actor attended the Dior Homme Fashion
Show I don't know why I wasn't invited
but yeah luckily we got to see the posts
on social media when the motorbike
leaked image dropped last week many fans
were disappointed that his hair was more
Brown than black however in these photos
they've clearly darkened his hair and it
is now likely that that scene could be
Wayne on the motorcycle with his helmet
on that we did see him wearing or rather
a stuntman was wearing okay the pants oh
look at the pants different that's what
was spot on this channel we spot the
little details that you missed put a red
circle around it as they are shooting
the scenes in door now Pattinson hair
will likely have to be in line with his
appearance in the film so this will
probably be how he looks in the final
cut of the film similar to this Colin
Farrell has also been spotted out and
about in LA with the look that he will
be sporting for Gotham's biggest crime
lord the penguin last week we also got
some behind the scenes blurry images of
the character but now we can see what he
looks like in higher resolution and I'm
really liking the look I did theorized
that they would kind of take the look
from emperor penguin who is a big bad in
Gotham that is not actually Oswald
Cobblepot and it does look like they'll
lean more towards there and kind of mix
the two together that I think this looks
solidifies Farrell has also started
putting on weight and it looks like he's
committing to the role we have had a
skinnier penguin in the past as we saw
in Gotham but here it looks like he's
letting himself go yeah maybe he's just
doing that in general but he is slightly
more in line with what we expect we do
know that the Riddler played by Paul
Dano is actually the big villain of the
movie so penguin could just be playing
the sidelines I actually have a feeling
that they will connect this to Joker and
in the wake of Thomas Wayne dying during
his electoral run I think penguin will
have stepped in and taken over the city
Robert Pattinson did let something slip
about the Joker and Batman connection in
an interview last year that he asked the
reporter to take out of the article and
no we don't know what was said the fact
that he asked for it removed
show that there could be some
connections as for the Riddler I'd love
to see a zero yes or a feeling to it
where he was basically behind the scenes
controlling everything and setting the
pieces in place to take over the city if
you haven't read it then you definitely
should because it's great and basically
the first dark tells of Batman taking
down the Red Hood gang who may or may
not be led by the Joker and the second
dog tells the story of the Riddler who's
risen and taken of the city and he
basically turns it into a no-man's land
both are brilliantly imaginings of
Batman's origin story I definitely
recommend that you pick them up now
that's all of the news that we have you
should be fully caught up-to-date with
every single leak and report that we
have on the film obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the upcoming movie
and if you miss the last breakdown then
make sure you check it out after this we
go over the Batman animated series
blimps the news vehicles that
demonstrate the time setting the funeral
of the Wayne's and what could happen
there and yeah a lot lot more you can
support the show by subscribing to us on
patreon and if you want to come chat to
us after the video then join our discord
server in the description below or
follow us on twitter at definition
whitey that's the best way to keep up to
date with everything we do at heavy
spoilers and hopefully we see over there
very very soon this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best now see you next time
take care peace
you